you think the reason they're not as just
purely embarrassed the fact that this is
gonna lose lose even more credibility
with the audience that what we've been
saying this entire time we've been wrong
we haven't done real true Investments I
don't think that's it I think no I don't
think that's it if if that was the
reason
I could understand that reason I think
it's part of this implicit and explicit
collusion it's like this isn't the story
and so we're not going to report it and
I think that economically even that's a
foolish decision because Newsweek I've
been reading Newsweek recently Newsweek
has some journalists they actually have
some real information again which is
quite interesting though it's still a
liberal magazine yeah but but my
experience has been in the last couple
of months I thought oh my God there's
some actual news in Newsweek and so that
was that was reasonable but I see all
this
not only as collusion which is
absolutely appalling so that's the death
of Journalism because journalists are
colluding with politicians it's like
well they're not journalists anymore and
they're also not politicians because if
they were politicians and journalists
they wouldn't be colluding whatever they
are as a consequence of this collusion
is not politicians and journalists it's
some completely new thing now I'm less
worried about it than I might be because
I also see it as part of the inevitable
death spiral of the Legacy Media they're
dead and why well they don't have a
monopoly over the dissemination of
information at All YouTube for all of
its flaws which are manifold is an
unbelievably powerful and accessible
technology where the cost of Entry is
zero it's like no TV station can compete
with that period they're done and then
these print media sources especially
when they're great people Barry Weiss
might be example leave because they
can't say what they want to they don't
have to lose much of their talent before
all they've got left is hacks and then
everyone can publish to an international
audience instantly online so part of
what we're seeing in the mainstream
media is a technologically fueled death
spiral and I know how large corporations
die so there's this principle Pareto
Principle which is that the square root
of the number of people in a given
creative Enterprise do half the work and
so if you're a news organization with a
thousand people 30 of them do half the
work and you think no and you can think
that all you want but you're just wrong
because this is one of the most
well-established findings in social
science period
so you got a thousand people and 970 of
them are putting in time and 30 of them
are doing half the work and then
something shifts
those people can't say what they want to
say let's say the 30. the 30. what do
they do well they leave why because they
can right these are people they're un
these are competent people they're
really smart they're on the edge they're
tough they have immense networks of
connections as soon as the ship rocks
they think ciao you think I need you
it's like you got you got your
priorities wrong you need me they go off
like Barry Weiss did and start their own
thing and so then you're left with the
970 that was only doing half the work
and then the next 30 competent people
leave and soon all you've got is people
who
run the Legacy Media and they just and
they say things like well Joe Rogan
people should listen to him because he
just Wings it it's like how clueless can
you possibly be or or you have people
like at CNN who treat Rogan like he's an
outsider despite the fact that he's
pulling in numbers that are at least
five five to eight times their average
viewership
Joe is fringe it's like really we'll see
who's Fringe here and so and part of
this is purely technological it's like
there's no way these Legacy apparatuses
can compete how can they printing is
printing with universal distribution is
free video with universal distribution
is free how can a network possibly
compete it can't so spiral death and as
they die they lose their editors they
lose their fact Checkers they lose their
good journalists they lose everybody
with courage and then they put out
problem and they and they're tempted by
click bait because that's what you have
to do while you're dying it's like
Christ we have to attract attention
somehow so you say well Joe Rogan
apologized and everybody clicks on it
and they read it and they think that's a
lie and so you've lost another five
percent of your reviewers CNN is
probably sitting in their board meetings
saying God please we need Trump to be
president again because when he was
President we were making money we we
need somebody like that to be president
they're begging this guy to come back
can you imagine if CNN ends up like
putting him on left and right to and
then you know to berate him but at the
same time they're getting more eyeballs
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]